uh Donald Trump being dishonest and
scamming his followers
Say It Ain't So Donald Trump kept for
himself most of the 147 million dollars
that he raised supposedly for the 2022
midterms now you might ask why do the
same people keep falling for this stuff
over and over again we will get to that
Huffington Post reports Trump hoarded
most of the 147 million in small donor
money he raised for himself just weeks
after touting a new Super PAC writes SV
de te for HuffPost in the November
supposedly to help Republican candidates
in the November midterms Trump wound up
spending just a fraction of the hundred
million he had available
and he hoarded the rest for his own 2024
presidential run
the coup attempting former president in
October transferred 60 million dollars
from his save America leadership pack to
his make America great again Inc Super
PAC which was ostensibly to boost
candidates in tight races Republican
candidates it collected another 9
million from an existing pro-trump Super
Pac and then 4 million in new
contributions of that 73 million dollar
total though
only 15 million dollars went to electing
Republicans in just five Senate races
according to a HuffPost analysis of FEC
filings with not a dime spent helping
Herschel Walker in Georgia
a full 54 million dollars remains
available for the super pac's new stated
goal helping Trump win back the White
House remember in late September uh
Taylor budowich who is now the head of
Maga Inc and was a spokesperson for
Trump's pack told Politico quote
president Trump is committed to saving
America and make America great again Inc
will ensure that is achieved at The
Ballot Box in November and Beyond
uh he's keeping the money he's keeping
the money so let's get back to that
interesting question
why do the same people keep falling for
the same stuff over and over again
it's important to understand cult
membership
and it's important to understand sort of
victimization it's crazy that these are
the terms we have to think about one
reason
cult members remain part of the cult
is they have a strong belief in the
group's ideology that makes them
vulnerable to being manipulated or
controlled by the cult leader in this
case it's Trump I scammed you once and
again and again and again after the 2020
election saying we were going to
overturn it and now I'm scamming you
again it's the same scam because they're
loyal to the ideology they are
predisposed to be manipulated oftentimes
cult members have a strong emotional
attachment to the group and to its
leaders and that is absolutely the case
with Donald Trump that makes it
difficult for them to break away and to
stop being scammed by the cult leader
the cult followers also are sometimes
isolated from the outside world in this
case we might call it isolated from
everything other than Mega trumpism that
makes it tough for them to even get
other inputs about hey he might be
scamming you again friends and family
try to tell them you're getting scammed
stop donating doesn't happen they've
remain vulnerable so you've got cult
membership you then also need to look at
scam victims scam victims are often
victimized by scammers multiple times
it's really common and it fits here as
well some people seem to just be more
susceptible to scams either because of
their emotional vulnerability
psychological vulnerability lack of
Education lack of knowledge about scams
sometimes it's they're lonely
and donating to Trump is a way to be
part of a group or they have low
self-esteem or they want to be validated
Trump's emails are quite literally
exactly those we want to put you on a
list of Trump's best and biggest
supporters oh that sounds validating
that's interesting and then there are
some people who are just a little too
trusting or naive and they are more
vulnerable to be scammed so repeat
victims of scams really common cult
followers who just never realize it's a
cult really common and trumpists many of
them are that perfect combination of
people predisposed to be scammed and
predisposed to falling for a cult leader
I would say a charismatic cult leader to
some degree Trump is charismatic in in
ways that I think would appeal to Maga
and next thing you know Trump's raising
tens of millions again saying I'm going
to help 2022 candidates and he's keeping
the money what will he use it for
probably to try to help himself win in
2024 whether or not that happens is
increasingly in question make sure that
you were subscribed to the David pakman
show on YouTube at youtube.com slash the
David Pacman show
you know how tough it can be to navigate
the online news constantly being thrown
at us and that's why I love our sponsor
ground news which is an app and website
that allows you to easily compare how
any individual story is being covered by
different sources every story comes with
a bias bar showing the distribution of
reporting from Left Right and center you
can flip through the headlines to see
how a word or a detail completely
changes the interpretation of a story
you can even see each news Outlet's
parent Corporation so I can distinguish
between independent and corporate owned
sources right now I'm looking at a story
about Iran helping Russia build drones
for Ukraine and I can see it was covered
by 35 sources 17 are government owned
like RT and Ukrainian media
interestingly it looks like the majority
of the coverage is coming from the
center and the right making it a
potential blind spot for the left go to
ground dot News slash Pacman try it for
free or subscribe to get unlimited
access to all of their news analysis
tools the link is down below